[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend les
correspondances sur Public Sénat
aujourd'hui focus sur l'un des secteurs
les plus polluants de notre économie la
mode un secteur en pleine mutation qui
tende de manière plus ou moins sincère
de ce verdir alors les nouveaux
étiquetage prévus par la loi peuvent-ils
rendre les marques plus vertueuses les
consommateurs sont-ils prêts à jouer le
jeu malgré un engouement toujours plus
grand pour la fast fashion réponse à la
fondatrice du cabinet utopie les marques
sont-elles prêtes à entamer leur
révolution verte reportage chez Okaïdi
qui multiplie ses efforts pour créer des
vêtements plus durables et puis pour
réduire l'impact carbone pourquoi ne pas
rapatriser l'activité ici en France
selon Guillaume Gibault le patron de
slip français qui sera notre invité les
planètes sont alignées pour relancer
l'industrie textile tricolore mais
d'abord tout ce qu'il faut savoir sur
l'empreinte carbone du secteur de la
mode c'est parti
la mode une industrie polluante c'est le
sixième secteur le plus polluant au
monde chaque année plus de 100 milliards
de vêtements sont vendus c'est 60% de
plus qu'il y a 15 ans et cette activité
n'est pas neutre 4 milliards de tonnes
de CO2 sont générés par an c'est plus
que tous les vols internationaux et le
trafic maritime réuni la mode c'est
aussi un gigantesque gashido oui pour
produire un jean il faut 7500 litres
d'eau pour un t-shirt 2500 litres soit
la consommation d'un Français en eau
potable pendant 17 jours résultat le
textile et le troisième plus gros
consommateur d'eau après la culture du
blé et du riz à ça il faut ajouter les
produits chimiques la mode est
responsable de 20% de la pollution d'eau
potable à cause des teintures et
produits de finition et une fois porté
nos vêtements continuent de polluer oui
le polyester la matière la plus utilisée
relâche à chaque lavage 240000 tonnes de
microplastiques qui finissent dans nos
océans l'équivalent de 24 milliards de
bouteilles plastiques et enfin de vie on
en fait quoi de nos vêtements on se
lasse vite 48 millions de tonnes sont
jetés chaque année dans le monde
en France nous jetons en moyenne 12 kg
de textile par habitant et par an
[Musique]
la mode est-elle prête à faire sa
révolution verte réponse avec vous
Elisabeth la ville bonjour bonjour Merci
d'être la fondatrice du cabinet de
conseil en développement durable
utopie on vient de le voir juste avant
l'industrie textile est très très
polluante et en même temps beaucoup
d'enseignes de plus en plus enseignes
disent aujourd'hui utiliser des matières
moins polluantes du coton durable des
matières recyclables ou recyclées et ce
qu'il faut les croire ces marques alors
il faut croire
à minimal intention la chose à regarder
c'est en fait le pourcentage de matière
dites durable parmi la totalité des
matières achetées donc quand on parlera
peut-être du Fashion pack tout à l'heure
qui est un engagement collectif
l'engagement pris par les marques c'est
25% de matières premières durable à 2025
mais quand on regarde une marque très
engagée comme picture qui fait des
vêtements un peu pour les sports outdoor
eux ils sont à 100% des vêtements qui
contiennent au moins 50% de matière
durable on a des entreprises comme Chloé
s'engage sur 90% de matière durables à
horizon de mémoire 2025 ou 2030 donc en
fait c'est le pourcentage première chose
à regarder qui compte évidemment il y a
la question de la matière aussi la
conception les modes de fabrication sont
très polluants énergivore et mettre des
gaz à effet de serre
là encore est-ce que les marques font
des efforts un tiers des marques et
proprement incapable de dire d'où
viennent les vêtements donc si vous
voulez travailler sur la partie
production il faut connaître non
seulement votre fournisseur direct mais
le fournisseur de fournisseur etc etc
avoir beaucoup d'informations et ces
informations là sont pas disponibles je
parlais de pitcher tout à l'heure qui
est une marque à outdoor eux ils ont
travaillé sur l'impact ils ont identifié
que la filature c'était je crois plus de
10% de leur bilan carbone donc de leur
impact sur le climat donc ils sont dit
il faut qu'on aille travailler on a un
filateur de coton à en Turquie la
Turquie c'est un pays où l'énergie
principale c'est du charbon donc ils ont
dit on va aller je crois qu'ils sont
associés Décathlon d'ailleurs pour faire
ça qui avait le même fournisseur
convaincre ce fournisseur de passer à
l'énergie solaire pour la moitié de ses
approvisionnements ce niveau de finesse
de travail il est il commence tout juste
dans l'industrie après il y a la
question en aval du recyclage on est
très en retard en France 48 millions de
tonnes de vêtements sont jetés pour le
pousser dans le monde chaque année si on
recycle le mieux on règle une partie du
problème ou pas en fait pas vraiment on
va peut-être en reparler mais le vrai
problème de l'industrie c'est ce qu'on
appelle la fast fashion c'est-à-dire les
volumes de production le nombre de
collections l'avalanche de promotion en
continu etc historiquement il y avait
deux collections par an aujourd'hui sur
certaines marques on est à plus de 5 ans
donc c'est c'est ça le problème
principal et donc dire on va résoudre ça
avec le recyclage il est nécessaire le
recyclage mais c'est une toute petite
partie je l'ai dit à la fin de vie c'est
une toute petite partie de l'impact
par ailleurs on recycle 1% à peu près de
ce qu'on met sur le marché chaque année
et ce qu'on met sur sur le marché chaque
année augmente de 4 à 5% par an donc
c'est pas le recyclage qui va résoudre
le problème de l'impact il faut le faire
mais avoir conscience que c'est une
partie d'un tout et plutôt une petite
partie d'un tout c'est intéressant Julia
fort c'est la marque loupe la plateforme
de la marque loom qui est très engagée
les accords de Paris là c'est clair la
production vestimentaire doit être
divisée par 3 d'ici 2050 j'ai du mal à
imaginer les marques se tirent une balle
dans le pied en réduisant autant leur
chiffre d'affaires leur volume à nouveau
c'est le sujet de la croissance des
croissances il faut être sélectif c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on veut voir croître et
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire décroître ce
qu'on voudrait faire des croître c'est
le un très grand volume de vêtements qui
augmente très vite qui sont vendus à
très bas prix dans des conditions
d'ailleurs environnementales et sociales
ce qu'on a pas parlé social douteuses et
donc c'est possible demain pour une
entreprise de avec un chiffre d'affaires
moindre de gagner plus d'argent si il y
a plus de marge sur les vêtements s'ils
sont plus qualitatifs s'ils sont vendus
plus cher etc vous pouvez en vendre
moins
de payer plus cher oui mais aujourd'hui
il y a un gaspillage vestimentaire comme
on a un gaspillage alimentaire on a je
crois que c'est Marks et Spencer qui
avait estimé ça en Europe 50% des
vêtements dont nous armoires qui sont
portés moins d'une fois par an donc la
question c'est dans l'avoir moins
peut-être des plus durable auquel on est
plus attaché qu'on fait réparer tout le
monde a son jean son pull fétiche etc on
en a pas besoin d'autant en fait c'est
ça le sujet après pour les marques à la
question des invendus qui sont souvent
détruits sauf que depuis le 1er janvier
2022 la loi AGEC interdit la destruction
des textiles invendus est-ce que les
marques jouent le jeu
pour la plupart évidemment parce que
toute façon elles n'ont pas le choix
puis vous vous souvenez il y avait eu le
scandale de burberries qui avait brûlé
des invendus etc donc en termes de
réputation c'est pas terrible et pour
cette raison là les marques ont quand
même anticipé d'ailleurs la mise en
application de la loi Ajax sur le volet
que vous évoquez aujourd'hui elles
jouent le jeu alors il y a eu des petits
scandales médiatiques aussi parce
qu'elles beaucoup d'invendus sont donnés
à des associations du coup finissent
dans les pays du Sud et en fait
finissent parfois dans des décharges sur
les plages au Ghana etc c'est pas
terrible non plus pour aider ou pour
contraindre les marques être plus
vertueuses depuis le 1er janvier encore
une fois en vertu de la Loi Ajac et
c'est pour ça qu'on fait cette émission
aujourd'hui sur l'industrie textile et
sur la Bible il y a ce nouvel étiquetage
qui est obligatoire les marques sont
censées donner tout un tas
d'informations sur la provenance des
produits est-ce que c'est effectif déjà
où est-ce qu'on est au tout début en
même temps laisse un peu le temps on est
vraiment quelques jours après la 2023 il
y aura un avant un après il y aura un
avant un après sachant que ça concerne
les marques qui font plus de 50 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires de mémoire
les pièces qui font plus de 25000 pièces
et les pièces nouvelles qui seront mises
en vente à partir du 1er janvier
autrement dit tout ce qui est en magasin
et en solde en ce moment n'est pas
concerné on a beaucoup parlé des marques
Elisabeth la ville j'ai envie de dire
les consommateurs maintenant dans tout
ça est-ce qu'il y a pas un comportement
schizophrène je sais pas s'il faut le
dire comme ça des consommateurs qui
attendent des marques quand on les
interroge ils attendent des
consommateurs que les marques soient
engagés en faveur en faveur du climat du
développement durable et en même temps
la fast fashion fait un carton les
neuronaux science nous disent qu'on a
tous le cerveau un peu reptilien
derrière et le cerveau préfrontal ici
qui est capable de réfléchir de faire
des actes de consommation responsables
etc et qu'en fait ce que nous enseigne
le neuroscien c'est assez fascinant
c'est qu'on peut pas activer les deux
zones en même temps autrement dit si une
marque me parle comme si j'étais un peu
très fast fashion soucieuse d'avoir plus
de fringues pas cher alors c'est cette
partie là du cerveau qui s'active et une
fois que cette partie du cerveau est
activée je peux plus raisonner avec la
partie préfontral autrement dit quand on
dit oui mais les consommateurs veulent
que on a les consommateurs qu'on mérite
si les marques de mains parlent à
l'intelligence de chacun qui est en
chacun et ben elles auront des
consommateurs plus intelligents et elles
pourront mais évidemment il faut
pourront amener des actes qui vont plus
dans le sens de la consommation
responsable et faire des choix qui vont
moins dans le sens d'une espèce de fast
fashion freinetic en revanche elle peut
pas elles peuvent pas faire les deux
allez merci beaucoup Elisabeth Laville
font un triste du cabinet top et merci à
vous merci David on vient de le voir
[Musique]